[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue chez les rozes
éléments je suis à l'iss on a créé
l'épicerie il ya quelque temps et on
organise des brunchs tous les week-ends
donc on va vous faire découvrir
aujourd'hui ce qu'on propose aux
couleurs de l'hiver on est en plein en
froid il gèle dehors et on propose des
choses vitamines et gourmande c'est le
mot d'ordre d'un brunch et d'oncle avec
un petit clin d'oeil encore plus
gourmand que d'habitude puisque on va
avoir des couleurs connoté donc du coup
hivernale fruits et légumes de saison
bien entendu
e
alors je vous présente ce concert pour
nos brunch habituellement quelle que
soit la saison on a bien sûr la
charcuterie on travaille beaucoup de
charcuterie étrangères espagnol corse
italienne on a le fromage bien
évidemment on est sur des pâtes dures
n'est pas de presser pour convenir à
tous les goûts du chef de la vache et c
est du coup en cette pleine saison
hivernale
on aime bien proposer des brioches qui
vont être à la cannelle que vous avez là
qui vont délicieusement bien avec le
chat et qui est une boisson lactée au
lait végétal et pis c'est ce qu'on
propose également et qu'on peut faire
toutes les variantes selon la saison
c'est ce qui va être au chocolat et là
on fait des choses aux amandes et
aulnoye c'est une bague qu'un donc là
celle ci est au chocolat amandes noix et
noisettes
on peut faire auprès d'une rose on peut
faire à plein de choses plein de goûts
variés les chocolats etc ça c'est ma
préférée parce qu'elle est très sucré et
du coup je suis colère noire compense un
petit peu et c'est délicieux encore pour
la partie sucré on travaille les fruits
et légumes de saison donc là on est sur
le citron avec des petites verrines avec
une base sable et alimente coeur donc
c'est une crème au citron surmonté de
petites meringues ce que j'ai pas monter
là parce que c'est encore en cuisson au
four c'est tout ce qui va être la partie
chaude qui est essentiel dans un brunch
nous ont fait beaucoup les oeufs cocotte
donc ce avec une chips dollars soit avec
une tranche de saumon fumé et tout ce
qui va être minutes donc on fait
vraiment devant les gens ou qu'on monte
à la demande si tout ce qui va être
pancakes au potiron ou à la cour chasse
comme on veut surmontée d'une petite
crème aux herbes et ça c'est très très
chouette
donc on vous attend tous les samedis
chez rose et leon le brunch est prêt là
je vous ai présenté un brunch pour 8
personnes aux saveurs de l'hiver avec
des produits de saison
[Musique]